welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldiers first episode ended with a real
slap in the face to sam wilson and
everyone who knows what captain america
is supposed to look like
not this guy after handing over the
shield in good faith to government
authorities for storage
and caf smithsonian museum exhibit sam
watched in horror as that same
government just trotted it back out on
this prize pony
john walker captain free boat shoes meme
yeah we all threw up in our mouths a
little bit when this new cap appeared
but hey
let's not take it out on actor wyatt
russell himself he's a cool dude he's
just plain a character
that we're meant to hate with a fiery
passion that takes skill but i'm gonna
explain
who exactly this new cap really is in
the falcon and the winter soldier
and how when you examine clues in the
end credit sequence and elsewhere
this replacement cap is actually going
to be revealed as every bit a
true captain america as steve rogers was
intended to be
yeah i take common so this new cap is
named john walker
and his name has appeared on various cap
is back propaganda posters in
show promo footage and in the end credit
sequence in the comics john walker is a
soldier who gets enhanced by the power
broker
and hosts rallies pitching himself as
super patriot a replacement captain
america alongside
a crew of bold urban commandos or
buckies
walker stages fake attacks on himself
from cap loyalists
just to try to make him look more legit
and it ends up kind of working because
steve rogers confronts him directly but
eventually has to step away from the
captain america title after
disagreements with the government so
then the government takes back the title
they
pass on falcon sam wilson doubting the
country is ready for a black captain
america
and then they decide to make john walker
the new official captain america during
this time walker actually gets trained
by taskmaster to copy cap's fighting
style
and he goes on to keep the cap title for
30 issues this guy goes
nuts he brutally kills his enemies and
eventually the us government turns
walker into a new figure named us
agent and yeah you can already see how a
lot of this is being paralleled in what
we know about the falcon in the winter
soldier
walker hosts patriotic rallies at
football games his uniform matching the
red stripes across the chest of the us
agent uniform he carries a gun on his
hip suggesting he is not as hesitant to
take lives as steve rogers was clay
bennett is playing a character many
believe is battle star lamar hoskins
one of walker's bouldering commandos in
the comics and we see the government
lying to sam telling them donating the
shield to a museum was the right thing
to do just to go behind him and give it
to a guy who looks like steve rogers
and taskmaster is showing up in black
widow which we have speculated might
have some crossovers with the falcon and
winter soldier now the words
power broker is watching appear in the
end credits a
major clue that marvel's power broker
carl malus or
maybe he's gonna be given a different
identity since the name carmalis showed
up in the netflix defenders universe and
jessica jones
some power broker could be coming into
play and in addition to enhancing john
walker and lamar hoskins power broker
also goes on to experiment on
joaquin torres making him the new falcon
taking over
after sam takes over cap's title and now
joaquin torres is in this series as well
he's sam's mission partner sticking his
nose into sam's red wing tech
additionally we see the text according
to thaddeus ross
all information regarding the enhanced
humans act
has been reported to be classified by
major donovan of special unit
thaddeus ross also returning in black
widow
this guy was secretary of state back in
civil war and the avengers really pissed
him off during civil war and
an infinity war when roadie hung up on
him arrest them
all over it
that's a court martial boom you're
looking for a very short stay in
washington dc
thanks to policy genius for sponsoring
this video if you have family members
who depend on you you need life
insurance if i was gone tomorrow not
only would the world be without a
preeminent expert on zooming and
enhancing random pictures hanging on the
walls of mcu scenes but my dependence
would also be without my financial
support if life insurance is so
essential
why is buying it so complicated well
policy genius asks themselves that
question they started a company that
reinvented the process from start to
finish
policy genius lets you compare life
insurance rates and save 50
or more in the process that means more
cash to put toward the things you care
about
like replica paintings from the walls of
mcu scenes policy genius is an insurance
marketplace not an insurance company
they get you personalized quotes from
top companies in minutes
with policy genius you can easily apply
online and compare your quotes all
in one place and policy genius doesn't
add on those extra fees
you could save thirteen hundred dollars
or more per year by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies you
can save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius just visit
policygenius.com
new rockstars to shop the market and
start saving today
that's policygenius.com new rockstars so
with thaddeus ross is still a big player
in the mcu
present at tony stark's funeral and i
have speculated he could even be a
natural candidate to ascend into the
presidency after secretary of state
which could have made him behind bucky's
conditional pardon
maybe even a pardon for sam wilson as a
fellow violator of the sokovia accords
which might include a requirement to go
on these dangerous missions where air
force ops guys could be trying to
sabotage his tech
either way we know ross was
experimenting with human enhancement
during the events of incredible hulk
when he was attempting to reboot cap's
super soldier program that's what led to
whole and led to blonsky who became
abomination the fact that this was
legislation in the mcu tells us there
have been
other enhanced human test subjects in
this world and we might have seen one of
those test subjects
in this other slide from the end credits
research log
for subject 02656 in the face of actor
carl lumbling we believe lumbly is
playing isaiah bradley the black captain
america
an african-american soldier enhanced
with super soldier serum whose history
ended up being overshadowed and more or
less erased by the government
show creator malcolm spellman promised
this series would address
race in sam's struggle with the legacy
of captain america and sam being passed
over for john walker as a successor for
the shield
is an all too common thing that isaiah
bradley would definitely be able to help
sam
understand the cruel historical context
of now with zemo returning the falcon in
the winter soldier is presenting itself
as the kind of next chapter of the
captain america series
after civil war and that film hinged on
bucky's pivotal reveal
because i'm not the only winner soldier
and i think this show will make a
similar reveal
that there was more than one captain
america in the way steve rogers was a
boy scout poster boy propaganda tool
whose legacy overshadowed
other heroes so too is this new captain
america john walker whom in credits
graffiti even calls out as a
manufactured hero but what made steve
rogers great is the way he resisted that
whole song and dance
charging into harm's way not for glory
but to save his friend
and a whole bunch of other pows i
analyzed in my infinity saga
breakdown series that cap didn't truly
mature until the second movie in which
he begins to embody the steadfast
courage of the winter soldier not the
bucky winner soldier but lowercase wns
as it was coined by thomas payne in 1776
the soldier who fights on even when
everyone else has abandoned him
and this leads ultimately to steve
rejecting that flag in civil war when he
walks out on that airport tarmac
he has torn off his shoulder patch so
looking ahead into this show the fear
is a captain america who loves the
spotlight
and that is who this guy is john walker
and sam will have to learn that to
protect cap's legacy
he will have to fight those government
forces who could never see
past the colors of that shield hey to
support this channel check out our great
merch options including our new latest
obsession number three
anarchy assembled inspired by this
awesome imagery we've been talking about
you can get it at newrockstartsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
marvel thank you for watching
[Music]
you